[Musique]
Dans chaque communauté civilisée, il y a un
paria dès son plus jeune âge. Le paria a
du mal à s'intégrer, peut parfois se sentir
invisible,
merci et a souvent du mal à
trouver un partenaire, mais l'araignée est le
paria qui cherche toujours une connexion.
[Musique]
que parlez s'il vous plaît demandez l'honneur de
votre amitié comment allez-vous bienvenue chez
nos nouveaux frêles il se passe quelque chose
ici ces cochons mystérieux et bizarres ai-
je raison cette partie à leur sujet j'admire vraiment
je ne fais pas confiance à votre opinion ce n'est pas
moi docteur oui nous  J'ai une victime de brûlures ici,
qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant tu me demandes tu
as essayé de nous le dire mais nous n'avons pas écouté
nous allons récupérer ces œufs allez, nous
sommes des oiseaux des oiseaux descendants de
dinosaures nous ne sommes pas censés le faire  sois gentil
oh ouais, point repose en paix par le
four, fais
éclater tes noix pour bouger tes fesses, il est
temps de se mettre en colère contre les voitures,
elle peut tirer des boules de feu avec ses fesses
[Musique] il y a
un vrai oiseau dans ces lofts, amène-le-
moi pas dedans  ces murs du
château, venez à vous les gars